okay let's talk a little bit about
what's going on with the situation
involving Roger ails and Donald Trump
and you might say David wait a second I
know about the Roger Ailes situation
resigned in shame from Fox News with a
40 million dollar golden parachute after
being accused of sexual harassment by 20
women gretchen carlson as i told you
yesterday receive the 20 million dollar
settlement uh in addition to the two
settlements that i'm not sure on the
figures for for two of the other
accusers and then you've got donald
trump who is maybe the most unqualified
person running for president in a long
time those are two separate stories
they're not because Roger Ailes is
actually advising Donald Trump and
Gabriel Sherman reports that he
interviewed 18 of the women who shared
accounts of ales offering job
opportunities if they would perform
sexual favors for him and for his
friends etc etc we have a situation here
where a vicious misogynist and workplace
predator in Roger Ailes is working with
the Republican presidential nominee why
is this not a bigger deal that Donald
Trump is being advised by Roger Ailes if
Hillary Clinton were being advised by
anyone even remotely approximating this
level of vile pond scum behavior it
would be front-page news it be Drudge
all day it'd be Alex Jones all day it'd
be Rush Limbaugh all day be Fox News
etcetera etcetera etcetera if Hillary
Clinton had a similar situation it would
be the top of the hour headlines every
single hour now our Ailes and Trump
officially working together well I don't
know here's a tweet that Gabriel Sherman
posted where it is a a blurry image of
Roger Ailes in the middle they're
getting off of Donald Trump's plane in
phoenix earlier this week if this isn't
officially working together it's
abundantly clear that he is part of an
informal inner circle that Donald Trump
has and I'll go even further Trump
himself and others on it on his team
have been accused of similar behavior we
know that that Donald Trump doesn't take
sexual harassment seriously his own uh
well documented I don't know what to
call it questionable disturbing behavior
with regard to women uh has has been
widely documented his first wife Ivana
Trump accused him of rape in a sworn
deposition saying that Trump assaulted
her in a rage after a plastic surgeon
she'd recommended botched Trump's scalp
surgery since she said she didn't mean
rape in the literal sense uh but she
never recanted her description of what
happened Trump's new campaign CEO the
the the the guy who who is running
Breitbart news Steve Bannon has himself
been charged with domestic violence and
accused of sexual harassment so there's
no doubt that Trump is very very
comfortable around people who have a
long history of allegations like these
against them because Trump himself has
allegations like these against him not
to mention and I know that some of the
Trump stirs the trumpets I don't know
what you want to call them the trumpets
they get very mad whenever I mention
this but there is also the allegation of
Donald Trump being involved in the rape
of a girl who was on a member of 15 14
or 13 years old at this point that's
there to Trump's entire campaign is full
of racists and homophobes and xenophobes
and misogynist there's nothing
surprising about that element the
surprising thing is that it's getting no
attention whatsoever in spite of the
fact that the level of perversion among
Trump surrogates and inner circle and
buddies and advocates and people giving
him relatively harebrained advice about
is a campaign uh media essentially
silent about it I've talked about how
people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is zipcar which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each CarShare member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David